the most important death in mha so far
bakugo bullies a baby and deu loses one
of his quirks at the hands of shigaraki
this has to be one of the biggest and
craziest chapters in the history of mha
and we need to talk about it right now
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my M videos you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel awaken the true power of its
Quirk by hitting 2 million subscribers
do me a huge favor and subscribe right
now it is of course complete free but it
helps me out a lot and we are almost at
2 million finally this video will
contain MJ manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned in the previous chapter bakugo
was doing all he could to do as much
damage to all for one as possible in the
hopes that the villain will continue to
rewind to the point that he would no
longer be able to fight because he
became a baby bakugo hit all for one
with Howitzer impact and a bunch of
other overpowered attacks over and over
again and even though he himself is
severely injured and exhausted he
continued to surpass his limits in order
to deal more and more damage to the
villain and things got even worse for
all for one when the vestages of the
quirks he had stolen began rebelling
against him on the inside with the
vestage of Hawk's recently stolen Quirk
seemingly leading the Rebellion all for
one was essentially falling apart on the
outside and on the inside and even
though he was desperately attempting to
reach shigaraki before he rewound
himself out of existence things were
looking increasingly bad for him it was
beginning to look like he wouldn't make
it to shigaraki after all like like he
was about to meet his end right here and
now at the hands of katski bakugo the
latest chapter starts off with all for
one desperately trying to recover from
bakugo's attacks and continue advancing
towards shigaraki he knows that he has
to give his Quirk to tomura so that he
can strengthen his Consciousness within
tomura's body overcome tomura himself
and take control of the body then he
will have the ultimate vessel and
nothing that happened up to this point
will matter the fact that he was almost
re out of existence won't won't matter
the fact that he almost lost at the
hands of a hero student won't matter
because he will become Unstoppable the
ultimate Demon Lord and He will finally
be able to steal one for all as we all
know all for one wants so badly to be
the main character he wants the world to
revolve around him he wants everyone to
pay attention to him and rever him and
he feels like he's just so close he is
so close to fulfilling his master plan
so close to achieving his Ultimate Dream
and yet as this chapter reveals it it's
already too late for all for one he is
now literally a baby just a bit older
than a newborn and he can't even walk
anymore he is crawling on all fours and
he isn't going to get very far because
bakugo is right there and he blocks the
baby's path now bakugo is absolutely
exhausted and he is also severely
injured he can't talk he can't move and
he is moments away from collapsing to
the ground but even though bakugo is
barely standing he knows that he only
needs to hold out for a little bit
longer all for one is about to rewind
himself out of existence he is only
moments away from disappearing and so
bakugo has to hold his ground for just a
little while longer when baby uler one
sees bakugo standing in his way once
again he becomes extremely emotional he
cries and screams and then he opens his
mouth and shoots a large spike out of it
and right at bakugo but bakugo manages
to catch the spike between his teeth and
Smash It To Pieces presumably all for
one is considerably weaker now that he's
become a baby and so are his attacks
bakugo smiles and says 99 All For One
Straight Up mocking the villain and his
new baby form this infuriates all for
one who is now much more emotional than
he used to be he literally has the
emotional stability of a baby and he
begins to scream and cry no no no I hate
it I hate it this emotional eruption
initiates the rewinding process yet
again this is the literal definition of
emotional damage and all for one soon
goes from being a baby to being a fetus
and then he literally disappears
altogether as he disappears all the
Quirk factors that he had stolen from
others begin to magically return to
their original users at least that's the
implication at first but then Hawk's
vestage says no not happening way too
big of a fan service and then Hawks
seemingly disappears along with the
other vages and all for one himself so
I'm going to be honest I'm not 100%
clear on this are the quirks going back
to the original owners or are they just
dis appearing along with all for one at
first it seemed like Hawk's vestage was
suggesting that they might go back to
their owners but then he said that this
would be too convenient for the plot too
much of a happy ending that serves as
pure fan service for those who want to
see Hawks get his Quirk back so which is
it did they go back to their owners and
then Hawk's vestage just made a joke
about how this is too much fan service
or did they end up disappearing because
as Hawks vestages said allowing them to
go back to their owners would be too
much and too fan servy let me know down
in the comments how you interp
interpreted these panels are the stolen
quirks going back to their original
owners or are they just going to
disappear for good oh and don't forget
to like And subscribe to support your
boy right here on the channel as aler
one's body completely evaporates bakugo
has like the most bakugo moment ever as
he finally collapses to the ground he
says oh damn it I really wanted to
strike all might's Victory pose and then
we see him lying on his back with his
fist lifted into the air as a tribute to
all might's famous Victory pose even
though bakugo couldn't quite manage to
make the pose himself under the
circumstances he knows that he's done
his part and that he won't be able to
fight anymore so he thinks do your best
isuku because now it all comes down to
the final battle between Deku and
shigaraki like I said this is such a
bakugo moment even when he physically
can't be a badass he still finds a way
to be a badass and we also got reminded
once again about how much he believes in
Deku and how much he has progressed as a
character from The egotistical hotthead
that that he used to be we then see a
quick flashback to a few days before the
battle when a bunch of the heroes and
hero students were discussing their plan
against shigaraki genus says that they
need to defeat shigaraki inside the UA
because they can't let him get to the
ground and use his awakened Decay on the
towns and cities of Japan the issue is
not just the physical destruction of
buildings that shigaraki could bring
about but also his Disturbed state of
mind which according to gist makes him
an even more dangerous opponent to deal
with than all for one All For One Wants
to Rule Japan so he wants to defeat the
heroes and then take over and become the
main character but the fact that he
wants to rule Japan means that there
still has to be a Japan around for him
to rule on the other hand shigaraki
doesn't have any Ambitions about ruling
or governing he just wants to annihilate
everything and kill everyone with how
strong and determined shigaraki is now
he could use his Quirk to Target the
ground itself and potentially destroy
large chunks of the country in the
process shikari could go from a
dangerous villain to the world's most
destructive natural Calamity a massive
Nation destroying earthquake back inside
the UA bunker we see the evacuees crying
as they see their homes being destroyed
on live TV and deku's mom looks upon the
Carnage with tears in her eyes she calls
out her son's name clearly worried about
his safety in the present shigaraki
seems to confirm gist's fears because he
talks about how he could use Decay to
destroy large chunks of shizuoka
prefecture and in fact he believes that
he could erase all of Japan from the map
in less than a week what's more when he
destroys Japan there will be no way to
rebuild it the ground will be unstable
the levies will be destroyed and
everything will flood and there will be
no usable land left it would be utter
and permanent destruction and this whole
idea of shigaraki potentially
annihilating all of Japan emphasizes
once again what's at stake here and how
important it is for deu to defeat him as
soon as possible this isn't just a
battle between a hero and the villain
this is a battle for the very survival
of Japan and everyone who lives in Japan
then we see deu using gear shift fudin
and danger sense to attack shigaraki
their battle is taking place in the air
over the land and Coastline of Japan and
it is an absolutely epic highflying
showdown between two Quirk monsters in
that moment shigaraki realizes that all
for one is dead and he smiles at the
news he says that all for one got what
he deserved once he couldn't even defeat
that brat bakugo but at least his master
plan involved making shigaraki much
stronger in fact shigaraki's modified
body is now so strong and so fast that
he is able to catch up to Deku even
though Deku is using fudin and gearshift
and shigaraki actually manages to place
his fingers on deku's face now Deku is
able to destroy shigaraki's fingers and
get away before thec starts to take
effect but even in that extremely short
period of time that shigaraki had his
fingers on Deku he managed to take one
of deku's quirks the panicked vestage of
dorano suddenly appears behind Deku and
tells him that shigaraki just managed to
steal shinomori squirk danger sense
shigaraki just stole one of deku's
quirks shigaraki just instantly
regenerates his fingers and he asks Deku
how long he can last implying that he is
about to steal even more of deku's
quirks and eventually he will try to
steal one for all itself this is crazy
the all for one battle just barely ended
the main villain Mastermind of the
entire story finally died and yet we are
already being thrust into the thick of
the fight between Deku and shigaraki and
Deku already lost one of his seven
quirks and not only did he lose it so he
can't use it himself but shigaraki now
has it and can use it against Deku and
sure danger sense is not the deadliest
quirk in deku's Arsenal although it is
extremely useful in battle but if
shigaraki keeps stealing deku's quirks
the balance of power will shift in
shigaraki's favor very quickly and
eventually deu won't even stand a chance
of winning shigaraki might steal even
one for all itself and become some sort
of Unstoppable Quirk God this is
actually really bad for deu and the
heroes yes the other villains have
fallen and the heroes have been very
successful in all their other battles
but here's the thing if shigaraki wins
this fight all of Japan could still be
destroyed so beating the other villains
including all for one will have been
completely meaningless so what will
happen next will deu lose more quirks
and if so which ones do you think he
will lose next at what point will
sharaka become too strong for Deku to
keep up with let me know what you think
down in the comments at this point I
feel like someone will have to come and
back Deku up against shigaraki but who
can even do it now that so many Heroes
and hero students are completely out of
commission could this be the time that
deku's father finally reveals himself
and actually does something useful like
the series seems very close to ending
and we still haven't met the father even
though hodik Koshi promised that we
would meet him before the series ends so
I mean if he's ever going to show up it
has to be soon right right oh and I have
to say that I really liked how the idea
of all of Japan potentially being
destroyed was really emphasized in this
chapter after all for one and all the
other villains have been defeated we
might start thinking oh shigaraki is
just one guy there's no way he can
defeat all those Heroes and hero
students on his own but now that we know
that shigaraki has the power to
potentially destroy all of Japan the
stakes will remain Skyhigh even though
the other villains have been defeated so
yeah I think this was a smart move by
kosi do you guys agree let me know down
below if you're looking for more epic
mha content to watch next check out my
full mha playlist link on screen and in
the description if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like to let me know
and if you want to help this channel
awaken the true power of its Quirk by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are so close